well this is the lib dem alternate
budget box obviously it's usually read
this time it's tears very clearly
Liberal Democrat budgets and it's yellow
and I'm now joined by the Chief
Secretary of Treasury Alexander can you
show you what's in the actual box so is
there anything inside well I've just
delivered the speech that was inside it
in the House of Commons setting out the
alternative fiscal plan that we as a
party would put forward because we don't
agree with the Conservatives that we
should be continuing to cut way beyond
what's necessary our plan would cut
lesser than conservatives borrow less in
labor get the country's finances back on
the right path and allow us to invest
more in things like education and health
and productive capital investment and
tell me a bit more about the box itself
where did this box come from it looks
like it's something that you just kind
of stuck the letters on and you decided
to put a speech inside it well it was
obtained by my office I'm not entirely
sure where it came from but it was look
it's designed to symbolize something
that I think is very important which is
that of course there's agreement in the
coalition that we need to finish the job
of deficit reduction there's two very
very different scenarios but how we go
about doing so I don't agree with the
conservators that all the final stage of
deficit reduction should be based on
expenditure cuts instead I think it
needs to involve tax rises on the
wealthiest measures to clamp down on tax
dodging more money from the banks in
order to make sure the burden is shared
fairly and I don't agree with the
Conservatives either that we should
carry on cutting beyond what is
necessary so if you like it's a prop it
symbolizes an important point which is
that we Liberal Democrats have a very
very different view both of the
Conservatives and in the Labour Party
but what should happen to the nation's
finances in the next parliament so this
is the lib dem budget then what was the
budget yesterday was at the conservative
budget it's like is this an admission
that you didn't get what you want in the
budget this was something that I agreed
to do within the budget negotiations all
of the measures in the budget the big
income tax cuts for working people which
Liberal Democrats of championed the
actual support for mental health Nick
Clegg's idea that he's been pushing very
hard for the last few years measures to
help North Sea oil and gas so on and so
forth those are all things absolutely
have had to be signed up to every
docking bomber by myself and George
Osborne as with every stage of economic
policy in this Parliament agreed equally
between both parties but behind the
neutral fiscal projections that the
it lies very different views from the
Conservative Party and the Liberal
Democrats learning it's entirely
appropriate maybe a constitutional
innovation is entirely appropriate that
I should have the opportunity to set
that out today